عبر البحر بدات ايراننا بشن او بشحن اطمان
من الاسلحه لروسيا وفقا لمصادر امنيه
غربيه استندت على صور لاقمار صناعيه توثق
العمليه شبكه سكاي نيوز البريطانيه نقلت
عن المصدر الامنيه الغربيه قولها ان
سفينتي الشحن العموميتين المزعوم تورطهما
في نقل الذخيره من ايران الى روسيا يطلق
عليهما موسى جليل
وبه مضيفا ان السفينتان كانتا ترفعان
العلم الروسي
وغادرتا ميناء امير اباد الايراني متجهتين
الى روسيا عبر بحر قزوين ووفقا لمعلومات
المصدر الامني وصور الاقمار الصناعيه فان
السفينه
تحملان نحو 100 فان السفينتين عفوا اذا
تحملان نحو 100 مليون قطعه ذخيره بهدف
تجديد مخزوناتها على خط المواجهه في
اوكرانيا وهذه الذخيره خاصه
خاصه بقذفات الصواريخ وقذائف الهاون
والمدافع الرشاشه
وصواريخ صغيره للمسيرات ورصاص المسدسات
الكلاشنكوف مضيفا ان موسكو دفعت ثمن هذه
الذخيره نقطا مشاهدينا هذه المساعدات تاتي
على راس المساعدات السابقه والتي قدمتها
طهران حيث زودت موسكو بمئات من الطائرات
من دون طيار القاتله والتي لعبت دورا في
محاولات تدمير البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في
اوكرانيا وفقا الاتهامات الغربي طبعا
[موسيقى]